un mot de culture à présent ce week-end
c'est la 13e édition de la nuit des
musées toute une soirée pour découvrir
autrement les musées la culture
l'histoire notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs mélanie paquet
vous fait un point avec nous sur cette
programmation fait alors ce sont des
choix non exhaustive bien sûr alors pour
le premier rendez vous direction le
musée de la ville ouvre à nouveau ses
portes ce samedi 20 mai c'est l'occasion
de fêter ses 40 ans et de découvrir ses
nouveaux locaux parce que pour rappel il
a déménagé se trouve maintenant au rez
de chaussée de la médiathèque alors le
thème cette année le vintage c'est en
lien avec l'exposition temporaire et ça
va passer aussi par le rétro gaming
comprenait le fait de collectionner et
de jouer à d'anciens jeux vidéo
les traditionnels sega
amstrad va toutes ces consoles acquis
qui ont marqué bien des générations d
jeu pacman super mario bros des jeux
bien sûr qu'ils sont anti qu il est que
tout le monde connaît même si on n'y a
pas jouer forcément notamment les plus
jeunes générations sous leurs formes
anciennes il y aura un tournoi également
multijoueur et le tournoi ce sera sur
saturn bomberman donc un jeu vidéo des
années 1990 toujours à saint quentin en
yvelines on peut également aller visiter
l'abbaye de pourriels et chant c'est
tout à fait l'abbaye se rend visite
libre toute la soirée avec une ouverture
exceptionnelle celle de l'oratoire qui
accueillait à l'origine le premier musée
et les vitraux seront éclairés et à
partir de 20 heures vous pourrez
assister à un concert promenade le thème
retour sur la musique des xviie et
xviiie siècles avec violoncelle et
clavecin
et troisième et dernier rendez-vous une
visite insolite à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines vous pourrez
visiter un lieu dans le noir c'est la
maison triolet aragon qui le proposent
les visites seront guidées c'est une
manière inédite de découvrir la maison
des célèbres auteurs et poètes alors les
premières visites débutent à 19h30 et de
nombreux autres événements sont proposés
dans les yvelines notamment
l'incontournable cité royale versailles
alors pour en découvrir un peu plus sur
toute la programmation le site officiel
du ministère de la culture s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci mélanie pour toutes
ces idées de sorties